electronic troubles are next week and
what would the electron ship will be
without some electronic artists
minecraft salad white trash men and
women who make sports games and I'm
battlefield had a bunch of other stuff
let's talk about EA actually first of
all let's not talk about their their
staples let's talk about a game that we
haven't seen in a long long time which
we haven't seen much of it all we got a
little bit of a tease of the last year
Mass Effect Andromeda actually seen more
of it than EA would probably like us to
see yes that's true centering that leak
Risa yeah recently there was it was like
a graphics nice yeah YouTube video like
just a rogue youtube video of Mass
Effect Andromeda yeah like gameplay
stuff and yeah it looks I didn't realize
how excited i was for Mass Effect
Andromeda into what I saw that that
small video clip just to seeing a Krogan
again I just like just did the love mass
effect i love that universe i love the
characters and loved the writing and
just returning back to that series it's
gonna be awesome like I think the most
interesting thing part of it is the way
they're so adamant that they're cutting
ties with the original trilogy yes what
has me excited no assurance me
confidence in that yeah they know what
they're doing like a lot of series that
go on for this long they kind of they
rely on using some of the nostalgia and
the existing love ya franchise I think
or they even connected themselves in a
tiny way which is even too much I think
it gears of war for I'm like you don't
really need to have this be Marcus few
side effects of you just like let's
let's draw a line in the sand here yeah
I'm afraid to cut the ties completely
with this game Andromeda it feels like
they're they're ready to start again
start afresh and you know maybe this is
the start of a brand new trilogy yeah
yeah I reckon it definitely will be
considering how successful mass effect
has been so far but like the idea of new
races new planets and kind of like the
technology way allows us to do now with
I mean to bring them back vehicles which
is right them yeah and like traveling
from you know spaceship to on a planet
and kind of not having any loading times
that kind of stuff that's just really
fast and even conceptually like Bioware
amazing in creating these cool ideas
like the Pathfinder that's what you are
in before you were the Shepherd know
you're the Pathfinder and your whole
goal is to you know
somewhere for ya they danced with that
space opera stuff really well yeah
exactly as a performer thing being
confirmed is that the auditorium at yeah
I think it's erased has been confirmed
but there's so much stuff about like
artwork that has come out with refined
a.j.p so it's like you know puffs for
the hero door and yeah that's just
that's just gaff messin with ya hey I'm
doing that yeah and if Andromeda's to
wear enemy I mean it's probably not
coming anytime soon but in the meantime
we can always check out and Marrakech
and Rob boundaries sick video of the
mass effect right stay well favorite
move a couple of weeks ago 4d got all
the D too much d for you to take and
let's talk about first person shooter is
battlefield the first battlefield anyone
tell you what that was a weird week call
of duty in front of warfare came out
micro were in space well I like we're on
the opposite side of space when die
[ __ ] trenches we don't even worried
about space right now I'm worried about
the flu getting out the trench but I
love that they were like oh yeah
infinite warfare and the entire game in
communion ha that's a dumb name you
cannot get a more dominum and then you
were like battlefield one got an entire
series yeah an entire what entire
industry was like now that's fine that's
fine I make perpetuate down with call of
duty so the fact like I have never seen
a well okay i have but like in modern
times in the past couple of years i have
not seen people tear apart a trailer
like they did battlefield one they were
like data mining in your history youtube
channels which don't talk about games
taking this thing and doing a piece by
piece deconstruction of like Bedouin
tribes and you know what the german
soldiers wore on what fronts and all
this sort of stuff i mean i haven't seen
this much hype behind the battlefield
game in a long time interestingly those
videos are deconstructed the trailers
were fascinating videos totally yeah
maybe it's an amazing maybe it's because
world war one is inherently really
interesting yeah as a subject matter
something that actually happened totally
sure like and it's also one that we
don't it's not like Saving Private Ryan
it's not like Band of Brothers it's not
like we had grandparents involved you
know to me it's it's it doesn't have
that touch like the First World War
feels like an alien thing that happened
and it also was like something that a
lot of people talk about because it
quite frankly was it was the possibly
the worst boy I was horrific and
answerable of civilian casualties all
over the world redrew the lines of
Europe and which have basically not been
redrawn much sense because it was such a
shocking event I mean what's going to be
a thing about the one is we know dice
are able to make war games but are they
able to make single-player stories which
like do a good job of touching on what
is an unlovely tragic human event that
is the acid test for them and I don't
think they've ever achieved that when
announced a single no I know they're
great multi-plane studio but they
haven't quite done it when it comes to
single-player campaigns so battlefield 3
and four were sort of the bombastic
movie stuff and most people didn't like
them too much I was a decent fan of 34
was kind of fine I mean bad company was
really go up a bad company was so much
of a like comedy yeah it was on the
opposite side I mean there was moments
of sincerity there but so in range seen
be a as a company as a publisher and
developer wider it's it's kind of
filling yourself with a lot of talent
that while not directly related to
battlefield like has a lot of
storytelling chops like they're working
on stuff like Star Wars and stuff right
like take a decade they could use it I
talent to bolster the storytelling
ability someone what do they do that is
you know but like the thing that's
really interesting is like the story of
its pitching and like the way dice had
to convince their you know their real in
charge that this is something you should
be doing and we had a story recently
about you know a kind of executive
high-ups executive leaving like the
worry was people don't know might not
think that what were one actually
happened right like the younger youth
right now just do it on to a disconnect
I promised a star to yeah they'd in the
same way that people believe Titanic is
a movie writing that actually happens
yeah i'm gonna be really really really
cynical right now but my suspicion is
that the the big heads EI thought well
time for two is futuristic yeah it's
been war we can't have two futures
across person war games launching at the
same time against another futuristic war
game precisely yeah so they have to go
the opposite direc- fall to you then you
know Vince I'm Palace second bite at the
cherry that first game respawns first
game was a
really great little game yeah very
interesting movement mechanics new types
of multiplayer you know there's sort of
two levels of battle happening at the
same time it did suffer quite a fall off
though in terms such a shame six weeks
into that a lot of people were done with
her fellow forklift in the oven six
weeks and I I was so upset about that
because I mean I got over it but but
five minutes ago yeah I was fine after
that like it'sit's I thought it was a
fantastic game my goodness um I thought
it's gonna be huge I really thought but
the one thing people wanted a tie game
let a single player campaign multiplayer
I you know perhaps just a byproduct of a
small team trying to make a big soft
first-person shooter but what do you
think about it something about that that
just read is really strange the request
because at the same time this is a team
that created quality and the modern
quality tablet as we know it yeah and
everything every time you speak to
someone about ecology they're like oh
yeah I don't care about campaign i just
got trying to Maui player well some
people do but I feel like a lot of other
people yeah and over to say the
opposition less like even I I was
someone who started off as a plain kind
of campaign yes it was like I'm on
campaign first and then I'll going to my
pet now I just going straight into
multiplayer but then like time afore
comes along and it's just a morir player
game yes exactly what everyone seemed
like they want here and everyone's like
where's the single player but do you
know why people went straight to the
multiplayer because the campaign's got
[ __ ] yeah true black ops one was good
call of duty 4 modern warfare was good
modern warfare 2 was ok black ops 2 oh
you know the and then we got into like
the Kevin Spacey stuff and then it just
became such an also-ran who in a game
that had like a solid multiplayer
there's a really strange contradiction
with game sale data which shows that
games that have a single player
component so better than games of just
multiplayer but it's also metrics which
show that when people buy these games
they just play multiplayer yeah it's
like the idea of having more content
like right like you're getting more or
more for your money up front even if you
won't play like the idea that maybe I'll
play the single player yes enough for
you to be like 33 pounds for all forty
dollars for it I think the titanfall
issue for me wasn't wasn't necessarily
single player it was just like it didn't
have enough content it was almost
refined too much like they had very few
like two or three pistols and by the
time you play like five or six hours of
it and you can see like that the top off
point on levy unlocking stuff and they
just weren't enough mech variety and
other stuff I think it might be deeper
stuff I think people like stories they
like universes they like to be
emotionally invest themselves in these
worlds that they playing and if you just
show the marinas or giant robots and men
jumping around the plane yeah that's
nine women doesn't grab you insightful
yeah as long as everything is like a lot
of that stuff it wants if as someone
who's an anime nerd and you know love
right now yeah like tell me more about
how this dude is summoning a robot from
the sky and about this is so cool like
and that's part of it it's a good
problem to have yeah I save are more
invested than they expect and obviously
these guys are they have grown
exponentially they're working on a Star
Wars yes saying yeah I'm totally they've
got the the team and the money to you
know we haven't we had a massive
argument about that in a way because I
think it's a sign of things not going so
well for them I think it sounded like
being like yeah we're on it we got this
yeah you could cut that one either way
you know maybe they needed a you know a
cushion in case Lionel do doesn't work
you know I guess we'll find out and also
coming multi-platform as well so
PlayStation phones can get their hands
on that one and a song with sports
there'll be a new sports game fifa
sports oh right the be new NHL well we
know that that's come soon when I think
the show and I went off yeah fifa fifa
beating on that engine like frostbite at
fifa yeah oh no no I mean Fox they were
using Pro every season bloody marys auto
fibro true engine for a while there and
yeah I'll show off all that stuff I mean
there's not much bring back mb hm for
God's sake they've done that again no
that last NBA jam was okay get Donald
Trump and Hillary in there this time
what's games in I know they're not
interesting to talk about and they know
they're not trending and sexy topics but
like they're amazingly success a light
they sell an absolution so like four or
five million every year oh toledo I've
bought PES and FIFA every year you
haven't played FIFA since rocket leak a
man yep
oh so there you go that's yet no longer
face through the world SSX tricky too
okay then I won't be too bad bring it
back I guess nice to do this let's move
on a little bit here and hazel eyes the
folks who made the brothers a tale of
two years ago they really some sort of
game last year it was a little bit of a
trailer for us they barely fair it was
like a dev diary which lasted forever
he's a dude on a train yes that was it
it was a dude on traeh hobo simulator
20-something you know I am okay with
that yeah so maybe we'll see and we also
don't know much about the sort of the
visceral mode of star wars game look
good Jade Raymond Amy Hennig working on
you know Jade Raymond the view of
Assassin's Creed fame basically herself
and Patricio they made Assassin's Creed
and you have Amy Hennig who was one of
the founding workers on the incredible
uncharted series voted 0 is coming over
there's word that maybe they might not
show much of it but they'll just do like
a paper announcement so they can get
more people to come to the studio to
work on it and yeah like well I don't
overhype people but that the planets
have aligned for that game yeah totally
right like and be like the greatest
thing and the fact that they got Amy
Hennig who you know made I hope make
untried and there's this you know bounty
hunter game that Lucas canned that
everyone really wants with yes Star Wars
was a good seven seven seventeen
seventeen nineteen thirteen thirty
that's like imagine da went look
everyone's going mad over this there
let's grab her and get to work Jade made
me talk of you talk a bit of a
sabbatical from the from games
development as well I mean on herself
and Patrice page one of the most
enduring third-person action games yeah
recent memory so I mean that's really
exciting as well I think depends how
much freedom Disney and lucasarts gives
the Lucas variety of the team you know
if they give them enough freedom a vague
of a me enough freedom to do her own
thing with in the Star Wars universe it
could be could be amazing yeah well not
to win see there you go
you